hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry and I'm
Thomas
welcome to reasons to see when we give
you reasons to see and not to see the
purge
so let's purge reason to see number one
the concept yeah this one has a
brilliant [ __ ] concept I love it so
much it's cool because evil I'm I didn't
really care too much for this film I
could totally see them making a
franchise out of it like even focusing
on another group of people doesn't even
have to be a family you could just
explore a different group of people per
movie talking a lot of people about
horror flicks especially and stuff like
that people always ask what is scary now
a couple days ago I just sat down to
think about this movie and I was like
just as a concept just the idea that for
12 hours all crime is legal and no one
can help you that's like utterly
horrifying to me yeah I think it's
really original I think it's um it's not
too crazy but you kind of are thinking
oh this might happen you know in the
near future it's kind of not like
outside it's not totally implausible
yeah it's like all this stuff exists
like you all we would have to do is just
have somebody with power put this policy
into play yeah and then it could really
happen in that sense so it is kind of
close to home that way and there are a
million ways you can do this movie yeah
yeah that's that's one thing I was
thinking about it's like this is a hard
film to sort of judge because I think a
lot of people are gonna judge this movie
based off their expectations of how
someone would execute this concept
because there's so many different ways
you could go about doing it maybe
someone's gonna watch this movie going
yeah that's how I would have done it and
somebody else might hear this concept
ago I would have done it totally
different and so they might not like the
movie just based off of that alone the
concept is much more horrifying than the
actual movie is yeah it could definitely
have been like kind of like a soft lick
or something where it's more about the
gore and everything happening instead
it's more like a psychological thriller
I guess kind of thing if this happened
to my family or what I participating in
it or what hanging back
yes sticky idea that it's really gray
and then the concept allows for it
everything awful yeah you could have two
wives in America for 12 hours you know
it's such a great what-if concept
because it just does get your mind
thinking I know people who haven't seen
the trailer for this and you just tell
them the idea you're like what would I
do if crime was legal for 12 hours how
far are you willing to go where does the
line cross between law and morality
yeah because one thing I really liked
about this movie especially in the first
like 20 minutes of it was they create a
world here where and I love watching it
cuz it's kind of you know some people
just see this is like a horror movie or
a thriller but to me it's kind of
science fiction like that everyone is
talking so casually about this the purge
and it kind of makes sense how there's
so many people out there who are used to
this kind of violence and reason I see
number two Ethan Hawke and Lena hey-ya
in every character and this is is kind
of a little two dimensional in some ways
but the these two actors really do
elevate these performances they bring a
love a strong level of humanity to it
you believe them as husband and wife I
kind of like watching that partnership
work together even at times in the movie
that I didn't like I have a lot of
problems with with the script of this
movie but even when the script wasn't
good I still liked their performances I
thought they brought a lot of they put
their all into what's going on you
really believe these these crises
they're going through and how it's
affecting them yeah I think they really
played their characters right with Ethan
Hawke being like the head of the
household kind of like perfect that or
trying to be a perfect dad and the mom
is kind of like a follower like doesn't
really have kind of her say in the whole
household but she just listens to what
Ethan Hawke has to say yeah she kind of
she's just kind of silent glue that
keeps the family together you know I
didn't really notice her stand out too
much but I like her I like her I
wouldn't call an arc but more of a
dissent in d'lita madness and she has a
great moment at the end a moment where
people were laughing but it's the kind
of thing where you're laughing because
you're kind of rooting for her at the
same time at that moment where she takes
out one woman smash just smashes
because that's the audience you you
wander at there's a really there's some
moments that that pose really good
debates in that moment where she has to
decide whether or not these people get
wiped out or they survive there are
certain audience members who were like
kill them you know just kill them and I
kind of wondered as an audience I want
them to kill them but from the character
standpoint I understood it but you still
get that great moment where she just
bashes that bitch's face in it and she
says that's the one violent moment where
I really felt it her dissent sort of
into like madness is really the big
question that I think arises in this
movie of because it starts off with them
like yeah I'm all for the purge but once
they get involved in the purge
themselves now they're like I don't know
about this purge anymore well yeah a lot
of [ __ ] for me it's like it's an
important day people need to let it out
but we're not gonna do that so it's you
know we're just holed up in our little
fortress so it's okay and then what
happens when that fortress and when
Ethan Hawke you know sort of becomes
Rambo at some point that's pretty cool
actually cuz I like that moment where he
shoots that guy in the back of the head
like six times to save the kid everybody
he first gets the shotgun everyone in
the theater was like what the [ __ ] order
where do you get equipped with that
badass machine you know reason to see
number three the villain he's called
like the polite strange yeah I thought
that yeah I thought he was more creepy
than anything is I think it was more how
intelligent he was because he use big
words and like some that I didn't really
understand so whenever someone uses big
words that I don't understand I'm
getting a little creeped out by them
yeah there's they're smart yeah smart
cuz I don't know what they're saying I
thought the guy did a really good job I
mean for a villain roles like that I
think they're hard to execute because
normally they're just some guy who's
like I devilish so nice my look like
this but this dude actually he could you
could feel a level of greedy depth
behind this guy and bloodlust and all
these underlying layers and you can see
how he's sort of like the leader kind of
like the leader of the posse at college
or everybody goes he came on-screen and
I thought you
captivating the whole time because it's
like you can tell that that character
fully believes in what this is on you
know on a level deeper than just like oh
I can do whatever I want it's like he
truly believes in the power of this
night you know at one moment he's
grinning and it almost seems like he's
gonna cry at another moment and it's
like he's not playing crazy I just
believe that in he's she's just like
he's off he was the only one not wearing
his mask throughout the whole time I
mean came in with the mask but he kind
of just threw it off and that I think
that kind of made him even more creepier
is that he didn't really care who knew
who he was his smile was probably one of
the more creature aspects about him even
though I know yes they are scary
technically yes but I wasn't afraid I
would have had like to see more like
explored as philosophies a little bit
more kind of like a cult the cult
leaders type of deal what you got again
yeah you get you get bits of that I like
when he shoots the one of his friends in
the head just a second when he the guy
you know kind of yeah that's kind of
like okay this guy obviously means
business like maybe we shouldn't [ __ ]
around with them yeah I mean you could
have theoretically you could have gotten
to know him I don't blame them so much
because it's like if you were in that
situation that's probably as much about
him as you would get to know anyway
reason not to see number one the wooden
dialog yeah especially like the first 10
minutes it's like purge tonight yeah
Birds tonight bird yeah tonight safe
night say United be safe a tonight
because we have your security system hey
I say two cookies nice house by the way
that you expanded because you've got so
much money installing all these security
systems are you purging oh no we are not
purging but we are like because we know
things will go wrong like the whole
reason we're here is because there's a
very dark concept and we know
something's gonna go wrong and I just
feel like the whole first half of the
movie is just sort of very thinly trying
to set up Oh things are great but
they're not gonna be for long and I just
feel like they could have used a punch
of writer to make things sound like
actual conversations I wouldn't say it
at first I thought I was just more like
the first act it started to loosen up I
can tell you the exact moment when when
they're sitting at the dinner table and
the tunur makes the penis remark and
then the conversation there
over each other they finally started to
feel like actual people yeah but you
know there was something about it in the
wooden dialogue that even though I
thought it was a little too expositional
and a little too I think even if I
hadn't seen the trailer would have been
like they're obviously setting up for
danger why I think is more like you know
they're trying to do a stereotypical
family that's you know in a rich gated
community like oh everybody's perfect
everyone says hi to each other that one
knows their neighbor you know that's
that's kind of what they're going out
that's what I mean it's like it's sort
of like the artificiality to extort of
like Stepford Wives kind of demon going
on but I think you can convey that with
interesting dialogue that's like it's
not that I'm down with that idea that
whole artificiality and we're all kind
of plastic and hiding something and then
we're all trying to you know act like
we're not barbarians and whatnot but
there's just something about it says all
the lines felt like there was like
here's information all right here's more
information all right like we forgot to
see number two not so scary yeah you
know a lot of people who see this
trailer or hear the concept are
expecting this movie to be like
terrifying you know well I get a lot of
people that's their anticipation so
that's why I think we should acknowledge
that it hey this film really isn't scary
yeah why not like you're dealing with
demons or you know monster there's
nothing really a horror movie yeah yeah
I mean it comes from Platinum Dunes in
bloom house yeah I kind of have this
creepy factors enjoy okay like skipping
along and like long like dress and their
mass it's not sort of the strangers yeah
exactly the strangers I mean you're
dealing with you know kind of
psychopathic people that it's kind of
the norm which isn't so scary I think
just because we know like this kind of
stuff goes oh like goes on in the world
yeah yeah I mean there's a creepiness
underlying to it but nothing really
there that's gonna you know make you
[ __ ] your pants yeah there I mean as far
as scares go it's mostly like jump
scares yes but you think jump scares are
kind of predictable in this movie yeah
the music stopped ridiculous there are a
couple of good ones I thought
but even so it's like I wouldn't even
call this a horror movie so much as like
a vaguely science fiction drama thriller
yeah I like science
yeah science fiction yeah dystopian
thing going on yeah yeah it
split-decision number one the kid okay
so I thought the kid was a was an
annoying [ __ ] knows how to do its get
good kid actors yeah there's good the
kid is uh that's the happening again
though I like that like yeah I don't
like the character at all it's like his
decisions throughout the movie we're
kind of like like you're smart I can
tell you're smart you created a baby toy
that can do like OCD factor phone cuz ya
know he's taking his vitals like every
couple minutes and everything so he's
kind of you know I can kind of tell
there's something up with this kid by
the way he lets the kind out yeah which
makes the girl go hostage but he's she's
doing his bed like yeah I understood the
kid like it would make no sense for
Ethan Hawke to live the guy in the house
but the kid is like struggling with this
whole idea like it's too big for his
mind to process and he sees a guy out
there just wanting to hide or at least
as it seems just wanting to hide so he's
like this is a big distressing idea to
him already it's clearly a bit much for
him to handle so we let the guy in I
totally understood I think because he
was just kids do [ __ ] like I think he
was just put there just to be like how
was this guy gonna get in here okay
let's have this dumb kid make a stupid
decision that's gonna affect his entire
family and I've been really I didn't
really think that he would have done
that like he wasn't really rebellious
enough where I think he would have gone
against but it wasn't an act of
rebellion it was an act of compassion
toward another human being like the kids
not the animal yet you know to the kid
it's like this guy's clearly being
chased by somebody he seems to just want
help like he's probably not in the
position to go like but he might kill us
we should just leave him out there to
die like it's a morality here's why
here's my hate the kid it's all his
fault why all this
a really really short movie they would
have gotten through the purge the next
day and everything goes everything would
have been okay way back they just they
feel like the black guy just get turned
over everything would have been another
stupid moment when he's playing with the
flashlight and then he sees the door
open and he's still like flashlight on
flashlight on and then someone might be
in here let me just point the flashlight
down dupa kids yeah yeah he's a
compassionate kid and it doesn't mean I
don't smoke I don't think he's a [ __ ]
I mean slays God why he was his
compassion to let the guy in really
wasn't believable for me because he was
kind of like asking his parents like oh
why don't you guys kill like kind of
nonchalantly you know and he was like
looking at the monitors like looking at
you know the dead body when there show
him the video feeds of stuff and he was
kind of like it wasn't like really
turned off by ideas kind of just like
contemplating you know yeah but it seems
to me like it was still distressing to
him because after once his parents get
in that whole talk about it's clearly
like Ethan hot was like yeah if we felt
the need to purge we would and then the
wife's like what are you talking about
and that clearly seemed to distress him
a little bit so you can tell that he's
at least grappling with the moral
implications of this whole entire night
like it made sense to me why he would
make a clutch decision like that be like
his compassionate sight makes sense to
me but his decisions made me not like
him when the whole you know game comes
up to the door stood the doorstep and
everything's kind of starting to develop
he's watching the video feeds keeps on
watching them watching it kind of just
like looks down for a second where you
realize it's like oh [ __ ]
I [ __ ] up I'm an idiot I'm just gonna
be kidding I don't think if I'm making
stupid decisions yeah yeah oh you're
talking about where it's just constantly
showing all the camera footage yeah in
that moment I thought that's when he was
gonna like be like okay let me find this
black guy yeah all right yeah that's
just killing but because it's like
either his whole family's gonna get
slaughtered or help save this one guy
and he's calm he's consistently putting
this one guy this stranger before his
family what decision number two the
daughter yeah the daughter to me was
just a
typical whiny teenager she was another
stupid one to me you know I agree with
you on the writing side of things I
thought her performance was fine
I didn't really get too much from her
performance she knows a wines or cry
yeah she she shows up for a second
like holy crap where is everybody leaves
show them again on the video feed of the
kids thing like I'm gonna go hide in
your secret plate secret spot gets
captured and then she gets thrown
against a wall knocked out that's pretty
much her whole yeah I mean I mean the
script doesn't give her a lot to do and
a lot of my big problems with this movie
are with the script itself but I thought
that actress I thought she did a fine
job I enjoyed her performance like she
did play like a believable kind of like
18 year old rebelling against your dad
because he makes you you know piano
recitals and all this set stuff in your
oh I don't want to do that oh I have my
loose tie because I'm a rebel like I'm a
badass chick and and then she kind of
just turned into like a little scared
girl like that's normal
I'm talking about the character itself
oh no like not so much to perform at the
performance is fine just the character
could have been so much better she could
have had a bigger role in the film yeah
much better written out okay there's
something oh and she brings the killer
boyfriend inside to know she done
that's the supreme he sneaks in she's
still running man through the family
that it's still like but it's still that
is not her fault you doing here dude
we're locked in here like wasn't dad
freaked out with you I know but still it
was like she was the one if I got her
fault
you know maybe it is him who is the one
that introduced him to the family though
it was hurt like the one it's not idiot
daughter who is putting this boyfriend
before her dad that's his is that little
altercation his boyfriend's fault though
because she said my dad's home you got
to leave and then he sneaks back in the
house I know it doesn't tell her he's
got a gun that shits on him
well her that is all his fault right
there her putting the boyfriend in front
of the dad is just another part of her
rebellious teenager you know I'm sure
there's tons of girls like that but in
when [ __ ] goes down to like oh crap my
boyfriend just tried to shoot my dad on
my dad shot my boyfriend my dad's
obviously in the right and my
boyfriend's a [ __ ] nut that's what
that's what I'm saying is how she's
another stupid character in this movie
because if she just listened to her dad
none of that would have happened but but
that's not fair though because you think
think about real life your parents are
like I forbid you to see that that
person that you're infatuated with are
you in love with whoever is like you
know what dad you're right
nobody does that yeah it's always like
we got to see each other in secret our
parents don't know even if you find out
later they do they're in this
relationship and they're like yeah you
know he doesn't know how mature you are
I know I'm older and that's a real life
thing that teenagers go through yeah
she's really dating this guy she should
have seen some signs of like okay I'm
gonna kill your dad it probably it
wasn't like a so you know he wasn't
really like you know the courage is
coming around now you know my
girlfriend's dad doesn't really like me
everything we're just gonna kill him you
know and now that was another scene that
was kind of predictable oh you come to
see me during the purge I was so sweet
oh no I'm here to talk to your dad Oh
even nice for you you know it's like no
he's come to [ __ ] kill your dad if
anything that [ __ ] is all his fault
because think about it what was your
plan
it's a I'm gonna sneak into my
girlfriend's impenetrable Fortress house
where we will be trapped for 12 hours
I'm going to kill her dad and then
expect that her mom her little brother
and her are all gonna be okay with that
and then we're gonna spend the evening
together you killed my dad dude is a
[ __ ] you killed my dad now you can date
me it's that's how it works
yeah they advice perfect kill the
girlfriends dad and it works every time
he's a sensitive guy you know she was
starting to take her top off easy oh no
can't do this you know I gotta talk to
your dad because you know I gotta make
sure we're okay I can't have sex with
you until I kill your dad split decision
number three the first half I like the
first half a lot more than a lot of
style I thought the first half was were
most of its originality was at you know
a lie I haven't seen a home invasion
movie take place like that before where
this guy comes in
it's a hunt for that guy and then it
deals a lot with this when they capture
the guy it deals a lot with you know the
morality there and then they pose
question I like a movie that sets up a
world you know it's where the first
thing that comes to me is Jurassic Park
for some reason because in Jurassic Park
they set up this world of what if we can
bring dinosaurs back and then the first
hour is posing the question of is this
okay or is this not okay and this poses
a similar question is this okay or is
this not okay you get it explore that
debate for like the first 20 minutes
through like people on the television
some people talking about it and then
the plot starts - then the story starts
to go and then there's more originality
and there's more originality but then
the last stop is when I thought I'd just
took a whole other turn but the first
half is the part I've respected the most
yeah I mean they do set up a world which
is really cool it's the whole reason
people want to see this is because it's
unique so and then I think they really
could have played on that more than you
know having just something going on in
the house I think they they set up this
world they should have elaborated on the
world a lot more yeah they set up a
concept where you could have a great
debate about it you could have a great
Philip there's great philosophies that
could be brought up there's so many
things more and there's psychological
elements and you only get hints of that
and you get moments of that but it
doesn't feel like it's something that
resonates throughout I feel like the
movie as a whole could have gotten
deeper with its you know exploration of
you know the psychology and the morality
of this whole situation however just as
a movie going experience I preferred the
second half to the first half because
the first half it was like I just all
the set up just felt so kind of thin and
wouldn't there was only the first act
though but there's still originality in
the first act
yeah it's original but I thought the
movie was better at doing what it was
doing in the second part because the
first half was like yeah no I get it
your concepts cool and I get it you're
searching for this guy in the dark that
stuff's all neat and I liked it but I
didn't feel like the movie kicked into
gear and got on a groove until the
second half because the first half was
like a cool idea
not so good dialogue kid made a stupid
choice there with the gun
when the strangers come in that's what I
thought like okay now you've caught the
groove and now everything that's working
is finally solid I really like the
opening scene and they kind of show a
bunch of like the security footage kind
of what's going on the purge do you see
how brutal it is and what's really going
on like outside of the world and I kind
of I kind of thought they were gonna
elaborate on that like maybe the family
is gonna skate and go you know into a
worse part and you know shits going down
there
I mean the real reason I saw I want to
see the film was because it was original
and when they started getting more into
the home invasion kind of Oh people are
coming into our home we're gonna defend
the house oh that's a straw dogs meat
meat strange yeah it's like gigantic
creatures blitt decision number for the
last half yeah like the last half to me
was that's when it just became a typical
home invasion movie it stops exploring
its concept it stops posing questions
and everything like that like I guess
the midpoint is when they get the black
dude and then they still pose a few
questions of morality here and their
ethical dilemmas yeah but this second
the parents are like we're gonna fight
back so whoa this is just like an action
home invasion movie all of a sudden I
thought it was so stupid like every
single time someone was about to get
killed up some guy surprises them with a
gun and kills the bad guy some guy
surprises them saves a day kills a bat
how every single one and then went down
someone shows up BAM saves the day even
when even was the one the black guy
becomes the hero shows up and saves it
like no I never felt like anyone was
really in trouble here yeah well yeah I
mean the last little ending of it is
when you know the whole the neighbors
are around they're doing that whole
little ritual prayer kind of thing and I
don't think one person in the theatre is
like holy crap these people are gonna
die like you gotta go everyone was like
oh yeah where's the black guy yeah oh
they just walked out no he's obviously
gonna come in and you know shoot some
people up I thought he was gonna kill
all and then the girls getting the wife
is about to be killed and then there's
the stranger it's like they show the
neighbors show up so it's like well that
was convenient for them
like everything just seems so convenient
for them to get out of it sure there
were some cool kills here and there but
it was just way too convenient and there
are movies that have I don't mind a home
invasion movie I don't but it's when it
just seems like a replicant rather than
not doing a more of a unique spin on it
it's it's frustrating when you have such
an original concept but then the movie
decides to kind of like can a lot of
that and just turn it into something
that is predictable full of cliches and
it's honestly loses a lot of its thrills
when things are just becoming repetitive
and stuff it's just like I'm just gonna
start killing all the bad guys too
the only thing that's missing from you
know being a home invasion movie is that
is that little bit of when the families
hostage and then the bad guys are like
you know torturing them or like talking
to them or trying to get it for me it's
something like that the only thing it
was missing after that just got really
predictable you know when the kid got
grabbed it was about to get shot you
know they think he wasn't gonna shoot
the kid he knew someone was gonna come
and shoot the guy you know and you know
in the Ethan Hawke was fighting those
two the two invaders you know and you
know like it wasn't gonna be killed
there you know you know there's gonna be
sick battle but you know he wasn't gonna
die then we're gonna kill them then the
thing for me is that I get actually what
you guys are saying about the second
half and it's not the movie in and of
itself has an original concept it's got
an original view of the world that is
very unsettling
however as a plot is just a story about
people it's not ultimately all that
surprising there are a few twists and
turns but I think the reason I like the
second half a lot is because I think the
second half is effective it's it's no
workman like is the wrong term I guess
but it's like I think they put every
they just assembled it well it's like
people are all running around in the
dark and I thought it was kind of tense
and then I was just worried about movies
and yeah
and well in it is because everyone is
divided and everyone's being hunted down
by these masked people like I'm just
saying for what it was I actually just
for purely what they were giving to me I
was like you're doing a good job with
this stuff like people were creeping
around in the dark and every time
somebody gets shot or smashed with
something I legitimately was like ooh
like every time a light thing got to me
yeah yeah it was more like cuz you know
a lot people going in just you know
we're saying horseplay I may be sci-fi
me thriller and stuff I mean as soon as
it turns into look like what you said
shoot him up and I kind of lost interest
that was kind of like alright I was kind
of set on you know getting scared
you know seeing some weird stuff maybe
like you know somebody get their head
chopped off or something you know
something kind of weird but I just got
done - okay shotgun blast you're dead
shotgun blasts Oh hit you - freakin a
pool ball you're dead no see I think
that like the movie has a lot of it
doesn't do it's not a grand exploration
of these ideas but the movie does have a
lot of exploration of you know civility
versus animal and primal and and you
know that sort of thing and so it made
sense to me that the movie would go from
a place of contemplation to a plate to a
place of we just got a fight now it's
like where the story pushed its
characters like I bought that thing but
Ethan Hawke just turns into like an
action hero all the sudden like that
white you know just a white undershirt
and he's running around with the shotgun
and that's when you're like okay he's
freaking throws like he's super tactical
or it's not like he busts out the
martial arts I mean every fight because
you get the sense that these people he's
fighting again it is over the top but
the people he's fighting aren't trained
assassins either these are all but
people [ __ ] around but they have way
more experience than Ethan Hawke to
having guns and axes what you don't know
this they have experience you have a
Sarah hater bit yeah you can you can
tell that they're like okay we've done
this before they're not like kind of
clear out there's a difference between
being willing to kill and having
experience as an assassin yeah but you
don't want to say they're an assassin
but Ethan Hawke certainly not earnest
out but he's been pushed to the edge
this whole situations pushed him over
into discovering that part of
self that he has been repressing all
this time he's been forced into the
purge he's an animal in a corner and so
I bought it based on those merits like
yeah probably with all these people
around them would have died but it's
like he's firing off seven rounds into
some guy's face that's what you do when
you're you know generate afraid in the
dark and you're fighting for your family
you know you're not gonna be it makes
economic sense but I hated the execution
of it I just I thought the executing
it's like you got all this tension all
this build-up like Act one world Act two
okay plot moving tension mystery you
know what's gonna happen build-up and
then the last half it's just bad guys
are in let's just start guns blazing it
for the next 30 minutes cuz what else do
you do like well you could be way more
creative with it it's like totally way
more creative with it no they could be
hiding around the house or something
like that rather than we're like hearing
about so much more secret agent then
then just [ __ ] finding a person I
just I don't believe that two people
would split up one with a handgun when
everyone is outside and they're all
armed and what a woman who uses a waifu
is like honey honey no no no honey this
is not gonna happen on your own with a
little gun and I'm gonna go around and
we're just gonna split up and just start
killing all that but yeah but there is
an innate difference there is because
these are the people who have wrecked
the wrecked their way into their home to
kill the man who is hiding out and now
because they didn't throw him out like a
dog they're gonna kill them too and so
when they're tying into the chair and
he's asking her just to twist the knife
into his gunshot wound that is all
Savage but when the people break into
their house that's all defense after
that it's like she has a serious problem
with the cruelty she's watching her
husband and act on this guy in a moment
of desperation what all the people break
into the house that's a totally
different thing because it's like now
they're here to kill my family and this
guy we have to defend ourselves with
whatever we have I know but I just don't
buy that they would go into super attack
mode with like person like you have to
because frankly only acutely practically
I know but I imagine they'd probably
rather hide more and then wait for
someone to come around yeah rather than
walking around the home alone it's ten
people who are like yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] about anything now that gets to but
that's the thing is because they live in
a place where everyone is locked down
behind gigantic metal you know like no
one's gonna come [ __ ] help them how
are they going to stick it out for like
seven extra hours hiding the people are
going to destroy their way through the
house it's like they realize that at a
certain point they don't know we're
talking about its ideas but you're not
talking about the way how it was done
that I believe there are choices because
what are we gonna do hide in your cubby
space for seven hours they're gonna find
out what you could have gone out you
know maybe knock down another neighbor's
door like come on help me all these
neighbors you will help you live in
already know they don't like they live
in a big home and you're gonna tell me
that when there's like 10 to 15 people
outside who are just ready to kill with
no regrets when this is brand-new for
you to kill it's brand [ __ ] money but
you're right they're fighting for their
own lives not I'm gonna go out and kill
does it matter though it's what human
being would suddenly go I'm gonna take
on 15 people let's divide us two who
have never gone on a killing spree
before just because you're trying to
protect us yeah just because it's
defense does not mean that they're gonna
suddenly be the courageous super [ __ ]
queer I could see them being willing to
defend something but they're being like
there are people who have three families
who have guns held up against them
doesn't mean that they're gonna be like
all right I'm gonna save that how many
people it was gonna save the day though
it was totally saving the day
it was like oh you think you'll achieve
the day I was like we're fighting for
kids like I I thought I wouldn't really
believe that family to do what they did
to have a whole shoot them up kind of
like okay we're gonna just take on all
these people who have freaking shotguns
and assault rifles but just burst their
way through my house I mean a day seems
like a family and that would have been
like we're getting the [ __ ] out of here
we're gonna find another place to hide
because these people are coming after us
well you know black men
yeah but they probably weren't they
probably the ones who let somebody in
and that's only because the kid did yeah
but in a situation like that you're not
thinking rationally
no one else is gonna let it let us in
you know we need to [ __ ] kill all
these people they're gonna be like holy
crap let's get the hell out of here
hopefully someone will let us in let's
run around the neighborhood ya know I'm
going to stole them all the citation let
me know because think about it why would
you run out like why would you run out
into wide open spaces least in the house
you have hallways and corridors and
rooms and [ __ ] yeah but you know if you
run out of people but they have trucks
and wide range weapon you're better off
killing two people waiting outside than
killing ten people or in Iran but all
those people are gonna know that they
left the house immediately how because
they have to go on the front [ __ ]
door yes who's staying at the front door
or go sleep now we had a backyard very
few people have some those people
probably had high-powered weaponry there
too like but nope it's so your size you
see it's more believable should I send
people than two people no I'm not saying
that but I'm saying you wouldn't run out
into the wide open Street where there's
no real place to hide and no one's gonna
let you in you don't way from but think
about it they know that everyone in this
house I mean not never in the house they
they have an idea the whole point of the
scene where she's out front talking that
brings is to get across the idea that
the neighbors don't like them and the
whole thing is that everyone's locked in
and no one's gonna let you in that's the
whole thing that's all reason this movie
happens is that the guy in there in what
you're saying would be their better
position they're the only ones who would
let that guy in well I think that scene
that you know heard saying that oh you
know was we we pretty much paid for that
second part of your house or something
yeah I think the way I got that is she
was jealous but she was just kind of
saying that stuff it's not generally the
whole neighborhood hates them cuz you
know but they don't think you get the
sense the neighbors don't like them that
I invited to this whatever party the
purge party they're having everyone's
got their security system at at the
point you're talking about to run
outside go knock on doors whatever
everyone knows that their security
systems don't mean [ __ ] so who's gonna
help them
no one is gonna help these people well I
can just shut the two people hop in the
[ __ ] truck and take off
no beacon Yuna five minutes that would
be that that's plausible yeah but what
I'll give you what I will say this you
shoot you gunshots fire outside someone
is gonna be there all those people
aren't gonna be pretty much there pretty
quick and then come [ __ ] another
stupid thing they're in a house every
time someone gets shot in the house
gunshots go off
you never hear people running towards us
yes because hunters act by like eight
people it's attacked by three people but
there are several scenes of people
getting killed there's that one moment
where there's three people that come in
that's it that one man then after that
more people come like people and they're
all looking for dad so last fight you
got people I said looking for him you
got people looking for the black guy you
got people looking for his wife and kids
you got people all over and you know
like okay bye let's talk about the house
it's like a [ __ ] castle
you know big the house was like you
don't they go to different rooms every
[ __ ] scene it's like it's kind of
unbelievable how big this house was yeah
you know from seeing from the outside I
don't think that's a whole nother point
is that I don't think they'd be able to
fight them and kind of realistically if
it was like it was a mansion like the
biggest mansion you've been into it
still wouldn't have been you know kind
of like close quarters stuff so I'm
gonna purge shots yeah everyone would
run over there and then they would've
killed whoever just shot and you
theorized of if they heard gunshots
outside people would have went outside
how come when there's gunshots inside no
one's running after them inside then yes
the people who broke in when there were
gunshots inside they're trying to kill
them go oh what real fast real I don't
mean the neighbors are that's what I'm
talking about
who is the first person who gets shot
the guy in the back of the head six
gunshots go off new Oh near anyone
rushing to that spot
yeah there's not one person no I'm
dancing around there playing piggyback
and everything knocking all the [ __ ]
the pictures off the walls and stuff
they're not like oh [ __ ] there's
gunshots to get to the basement because
everyone is right there I think the
Hawks someone in the kitchen
yeah there
one's to that yes but they're okay yes
that is a logical boggle in a sense the
only thing I can say to rebut that is
that technically I guess you wouldn't
know exactly who is shooting or being
shot at so one of the family members
could have died or one of our people
could have died it's a muddy situation I
don't know I'm just saying that given
the situation given what's going on for
these characters and all the weirdness
they've been forced to confront because
the kid let this guy in at a certain
point I get I believe it as a choice my
biggest problem is that it the last
half-hour is nothing but a shoot-'em-up
movie I thought I thought they executed
that thing well I thought that was
thrilling I thought all the hits hit
I don't just switch the genre on us all
this syenite sense they put it that was
the next logical conclusion they break
into the house and they say you saw
Glass House on the Left right yes okay
when the bad guys are in there it
doesn't just become up let's kill them
as fast as possible there's still
tension there's still there's still
suspense going on it's not just let's
hurry up and kill them and that's what
this turns into tension I mean it was it
was fast but I thought it was I thought
that the sneaking around in the dark and
all that [ __ ] list was it's not the
pinnacle of intensity it's not like high
tension but it's the movie but like it
is tense I thought was tense I thought
it was a little rushed like it wasn't it
I kind of took away from the tension was
like all right we gotta hurry up and
kill these people all right then happy
you know it's maybe even Hawke died
you're wrong by the way just I should
say yes my opinion is yeah
the way you the way I viewed the way you
think and feel is just wrong it's just
not right no yeah yeah yeah we can't
hang out with you I'm paying opinions
are based on yeah they're not entitled
to your own opinion yeah no no it's okay
you're a horrible person yeah no I'll
take your pain yeah Brian's consensus
there are a few reasons to see the purge
there are a few reasons to see the purge
yeah I like the concept enough to be
like you know what you might as well go
check it out because who knows it might
be what you're expecting jeurys
consensus uh yeah I think there are some
reasons to see the purge there are some
reason
to see the purge uh yeah the concept is
cool that the cast is really good I
thought and you know there's some
there's some tense moments and some
action in there so it's worth checking
out
Thomas's consensus there's a couple
reasons to see the purge there's a
couple reasons to see the purge
if I could describe this movie in one
word I think it'd be man alright guys
thanks for checking out our show why
don't you go ahead and scroll that
comment box below and tell us what would
you do on the purge anything is allowed
anything but don't say something's don't
ever trust an intern a moment or I may
Allah I love people watch our show but
don't have ever just an internet comment
board to tell you what they would do if
there were no reason because your eyes
will melt out of your face I'm pretty
sure most internet comment boards are
already what would I do if there's no
rule the purge exists if you want to
check out more episodes the reason to Z
click this link right here and watch you
go ahead click this link sake to follow
us on Facebook or click this link Oh a
little lower follow me
right right on Twitter and if you want
to get updated every time a new review
or a video is out subscribe click on
Thomas who's pointing at his crotch
pretty big leak right is good though
because it's proving that were equal
opportunity when every one of our guests
it's like it's either click boobs or
click a dick I got some pretty big tits
to some yeah you do like the Arnold like
uh I rather not because I would rather
you did here well I mean if you're
forcing me to dip oh yeah they're liking
you guys I think oh yeah I'm purging
you